use completing the square to write the
quadratic equation y is equal to
negative 3x squared plus 24x minus 27 in
vertex form and then identify the vertex
so we'll see what vertex form is but we
essentially complete the square and we
generate the function or we rewrite we
algebraically manipulate it so it's in
the form Y is equal to a times X minus B
squared plus C we want to get the
equation into this form right here this
is vertex form this is vertex form right
there and once you have it in vertex
form you'll see that you can identify
the x value of the vertex as what value
will make this expression equal to 0 so
in this case it would be B and the Y
value of the vertex if this is equal to
if this is equal to 0 then the Y value
is just going to be C and we're going to
see then we're going to understand why
that is the vertex why this vertex form
is useful so let's try to manipulate
this equation to get it into that form
so if we just rewrite it the first thing
that immediately jumps out at me at
least is that all of these numbers are
divisible by negative 3 and I just
always find it easier to manipulate
manipulate an equation if I have a 1
coefficient out in front of the x
squared so let's just factor out a
negative 3 right from the get-go so we
can rewrite this as Y is equal to
negative 3 times x squared minus 8x
minus 8x 24 divided by negative 3 is
negative 8 plus 9 20 of 27 divided by
negative 3 is positive 9 and let me
write actually let me write the positive
9 out here and you're going to see in a
second why I'm doing that now we want to
be able to express part of this
expression as a perfect square that's
what vertex form does for us we want to
be able to express part of this
expression as a perfect square now how
can we do that well we have an x squared
minus 8x so if we had if we had a
positive 16 here because well just think
about it this way if we had negative 8
you divide it by 2 you get negative 4
you square that it's positive 16 so if
you get a positive 16 here this would be
a perfect square this would be X minus 4
squared
but you can't just willy-nilly add a
sixteen there you could if you you could
either have to add a similar amount to
the other side and you would have to
scale it by the negative three and all
of that or you can just subtract a
sixteen right here I haven't changed the
expression I'm adding a sixteen
subtracting a sixteen I've added a zero
I haven't changed it but what it allows
me to do what it allows me to do is
express this part this part of the
equation as a perfect square that right
there is X minus four squared and if
you're confused how did I know sixteen
just think I took negative 8i / - I got
negative four and then I squared
negative four this is negative four
squared right there and then I have to
subtract that same amount so I don't
change the equation so that part is X
minus four squared and then we have we
still have this negative three hanging
out there we still have that negative
three and then we have negative 16 plus
9 which is negative seven negative 7 so
we're almost there we have Y is equal to
negative three times this whole thing
not quite there to get it there we just
multiply negative three we distribute
the negative three on to both of these
terms so we get Y is equal to negative
three times X minus four squared and
negative three times negative 7 is
positive 21 so we have it in our vertex
form we're done that and if you want to
think about what the vertex is I told
you how to do it you say well what's the
x value that makes this equal to zero
well in order for this term to be 0 X
minus 4 has to be equal to 0 X minus 4
has to be equal to 0 or add 4 to both
sides X has to be equal to 4 and if X is
equal to 4 this is 0 this whole thing
becomes 0 then Y is equal to 21 Y is
equal to 21 so the vertex of this
parabola I'll just do a quick graph
right here the vertex of this parabola
occurs at the point 4 21 so I'll draw it
like this occurs at the point if this is
the point 4 if this right here is the is
the Y point so this is the y axis that's
the x axis so this is 0.4 21
now that's either going to be the
minimum or the maximum point in our
parabola and to think about whether it's
the minimum or maximum point think about
what happens let's explore this equation
a little bit this thing this X minus 4
squared this X minus 4 squared is always
is always greater than or equal to 0
right at worse it could be 0 but you're
taking a square so it's going to be a
non-negative number when you take a
non-negative number and then you
multiply it by negative 3 that
guarantees that this whole thing that
this whole thing is going to be less
than or equal to 0 that whole thing is
less than or equal to 0 so the best the
highest value that this function can
attain is when this expression right
here is equal to 0 and this expression
is equal to 0 when X is equal to 4 and Y
is 21 so this is the highest value that
the function can attain it it can only
go down from there because if you shift
the X around 4 then this expression
right here will become well it'll become
nonzero when you square it it'll become
positive when you multiply it by
negative 3 will become negative so
you're going to take a negative number
plus 21 it'll be less than 21 so your
parabola is going to look like this your
your parabola is going to look like that
and that's why vertex form is useful you
could you break it up into the point the
the kind of the part of the equation
that that changes in value say well
what's its maximum when is its maximum
value attained that's the vertex that
happens when X is equal to 4 and you
know it's y-value and because you have a
negative coefficient out here that's a
negative 3 you know that it's going to
be a downward-opening graph that was a
positive 3 then this thing would be at
minimum zero and it would be an
upward-opening graph